two things that we knew were codified
number one
no mandatory postseason bubbles it's not
something the nfl wants to negotiate
with the union because the nfl doesn't
want to make a concession
number two voluntary bubbles are
permitted uh with the caveat that it has
to be players who are
not living alone presumably if you're
living alone you can't get in although
good luck policing whether or not
someone has roommates or family members
but you know i'm not surprised by this
peter because i think what's going to
happen
when it's time for the teams to lock
into playoff mode the teams that are
most serious about getting to the super
bowl are going to voluntarily go into a
bubble because their team leaders are
going to put the squeeze on the other
players to do it
right you saw that uh
you saw that kind of friendly pressure
uh in the summer in new orleans they
basically bought out the lowe's hotel
uh right near the french quarter in new
orleans and everybody like 135 people
of the 170 approximately
uh
you know
who were the tier one and two employees
and the players they chose to stay in
the hotel
now
i think mike one of the bigger things
that that's happened here
you would have had the players and i
think the players union on the side of
this
if and a big if if there were a lot of
huge problems during the season there
really haven't been a lot of huge
problems during the season
and in addition and i wrote about this
on monday in my column
the contact tracing program in the nfl
is has got to be the envy of every other
business in the united states the amount
of money the nfl is spending
on some of the best
epidemiologists in the country to
contact trace and i followed one player
getting you know
testing positive for the coronavirus and
then how the team found the one of the
other close contacts on his team
that also who also tested positive four
days later
and the nfl has done a good job of
finding these people isolating these
people
keeping them alone for five days and
then if they don't test positive at the
end of that they go back in the team
this guy tested positive on the fourth
day after exposure to the guy the
original uh guy who tested positive
that is what the nfl can do because
of the humongous amount of money they're
spending so i think players are saying
we don't need a bubble we've already got
all of these other things that we're
doing that basically act as a bubble
it's it's been amazing what the nfl has
done i mean to everything peter you just
said the protocols they've put in place
the fact that we've gotten this far
with
like you've said very few hiccups is all
amazing but man
but man i don't know i don't think i
could risk it if i was you know patrick
mahomes and company i'm chasing a legacy
drew brees and company
let me solidify myself as a you know top
five top ten quarterback of all time if
i can get to a super bowl i mean you're
right peter we haven't seen a lot of
teams you know for the most part it's
been successful
but you know we do have like oh i don't
know the new england patriots what would
their year be look look like if cam
newton had not got coveted i bet you
they'd be a lot more in this playoff
conversation right now so man do you
want to risk that that to me is just the
big thing we can see we see that you can
do everything right and it still can get
you know grab a grab a part of your
football team that way and i i just i
would think more times than not some of
the big leaders in the locker room are
going to try to edge or nudge their team
you know to go this direction because of
some of those reasons
the other side of the coin is this and
this is a concept mentioned in the memo
that was sent yesterday
the hotel experience still entails risk
you have to keep the guys separate one
of the things mahomes told me after the
win on sunday over the dolphins they
were back in the same hotel they stayed
in proud of the super bowl he stayed in
the same room he stayed in prior to the
super bowl it brought back a lot of
memories but the difference is you can't
hang out you can't congregate you can't
be around the guys and as you get into
an extended stretch week after week day
after day
in this voluntary bubble can you ensure
that there's enough distance at all
times among the players in order to keep
the virus from getting into the bubble
and screwing everything up that way well
why why do you have to do that mike why
like what i mean if they're in the
freaking bubble
they can't like hang out with each other
in the bubble that that to me doesn't
make sense you know that you got to stay
apart you still got to stay apart
because if one got because of the
doughnut holes in the testing and the
incubation period if one guy ends up
getting it somehow some way
you don't want him to spread it to the
rest of the guys
because they can't detect it until it's
too late
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports